on october 4th 2021 bill crystal an
editor-at-large of the bulwark went up
against scott horton of the libertarian
institute in an oxford style debate on
u.s foreign policy at symphony space in
new york city crystal was a leading
proponent of the invasion of iraq the
founding editor of the weekly standard a
foreign policy advisor to john mccain's
2008 presidential campaign and chief of
staff to vice president dan quayle scott
horton is the author of enough already
time to end the war on terrorism and
fool's errand time to end the war in
afghanistan he's the editorial director
of antiwar.com and the host of anti-war
radio and the scott horton podcast the
debate was hosted by the soho forum with
jean epstein moderating
well uh now for a major event of the
evening
the resolution again reads a willingness
to intervene and to seek regime change
is key to an american foreign policy
that benefits america here to defend the
resolution bill crystal bill please come
to the stage
[Applause]
um here to oppose the resolution scott
horton scott please come to the stage
[Applause]
[Applause]
connor please close the voting
the voting is now closed and bill
crystal uh there'll be a timer in front
giving you signals you have 17 and a
half minutes to defend the resolution a
willingness to intervene and to seek
regime change is key to an american
foreign policy that benefits america
take it away bill yeah yeah
thanks gene it's good to be uh
good to be here back on the upper west
side
not in soho even though it's
misleadingly called the soho forum i
guess or maybe it once wasn't for soho
i grew up less than a mile from here at
81st riverside so
i remember this this is where 95th and
broadway remember 96th and broadway i
used to come and play pool and ping-pong
in some now destroyed uh kind of kind of
old-fashioned guys and dolls type place
that made me think i was really in touch
with america there i was an upper west
side kid
so i have fond memories of this corner
fond memories of the upper west side
but in any case apart from being back in
new york thank you for having us for
this discussion i think it's an
important time to have a discussion
about foreign policy it hasn't been
front of mind honestly since
people like me who were concerned about
democracy around the world found
ourselves more concerned about democracy
at home
for the last four or five years and
still concerned about it i think they
are connected however i do want to thank
all of you for coming who are here and
those of you who are
watching it
at home
um i
don't apologize but i was gonna say i
feel bad that you all have to wear max
masks but it's prudent i suppose and
it's good that you're vaccinated so it's
nice that we don't have to well we're
speaking up here do so i've got to say
so the resolution as gene said i'll just
cut to the chase here since i know you
want to have a substantive discussion
and i do too
uh willingness intervene to seek regime
change is key to an american foreign
policy that benefits america
um
i think this is correct i think i would
notice that it says a willingness to
intervene doesn't mean you have to
intervene everywhere it doesn't mean
there haven't been ill-advised
interventions but a willingness to
intervene which implies defense treaties
commitments with two allies uh forward
basing of troops probably all the
characteristics of the post-1945
uh post-war order
uh i do think is key to a safer world uh
key to a freer and more prosperous world
and a willingness to seek regime change
mostly peacefully obviously
is key to a more democratic world
countries with democracies with
self-government
and with political and civil
liberties how to do that gets
complicated and i i'll talk about that a
bit too but i think the fundamental
point the willingness to
stand with allies the willingness to
intervene if necessary
usually that willingness is provides a
deterrence occasionally it has to happen
a willingness to
articulate
that people deserve to live in freedom
and that we should do our best to help
them and occasionally if they're being
oppressed sufficiently or if they're
being invaded by others
we'll even act to help them i think is
key
and i think such a policy benefits
america
directly but it also benefits the world
which in turn benefits america so that's
my core argument it's a pretty
straightforward argument i honestly
think it's a pretty um i think it's
correct obviously i mean the key
judgment people have to make is what do
you think of the post 1945
world order
if you think as i do that on the whole
it has been a good thing that if you
compare with the preceding 45 years it's
undoubtedly produced a world more
peaceful more prosperous more free
greater social liberties for all the
terrible problems
but compared to the preceding half
century i think you have to say this has
been
a good half century a good 70 years or
so by comparison all these things are by
comparison and that key to the success
economic successes successes and life
expectancies successes and political
freedoms success and just keeping the
peace success in not having another use
of nuclear weapons in anger since 1945
those successes really depended on this
american-led world order which in turn
depended on a core
defense structure the foreign policy
structure national security structure of
which the u.s was the keystone
um i think it's actually a great
achievement historians will look back on
the post-1945
first cold war order and then post cold
post 9 11 for the last 20 years and say
under-appreciated at the time lots of
challenges at the time
lots of mistakes at the time but
compared to what compared to what
one of the most important things in life
but i say especially in foreign policy
is not taking for granted
that bad things very bad things
sometimes did not happen
so it's pretty easy to look at the world
and see particular instances of failure
particular places things could be better
particular things that one wishes
wouldn't have done differently in
retrospect but if you step back and say
all in all
what does one think of this post-world
war ii liberal order global order that
we have undergirded
i think one has to say as i say peace
prosperity but also think of the things
that didn't go wrong the things that
didn't happen
and you know the soviet union did not
prevail in the cold war
liberal democracy spread intermittently
and with some setbacks in the last 15
years but to countries where it hadn't
been before
prosperity was expanded massively i mean
the achievement of helping
hundreds of millions i guess uh billions
of people come out of poverty especially
in east asia obviously in southeast asia
and china and india and surrounding
countries that does not happen without
the undergirding of this american-led
liberal global order
it's their achievement it's mostly an
economic achievement but their
achievement depends i think on
a general world in which they are not
fighting wars every 10 or 20 years as
they certainly were before that in in
east asia and elsewhere
it depends on a free trade and free
movement of capital
uh and the ability to learn lessons in
terms of international economics which
in turn is undergirded by that liberal
world order
so we take that for granted as if well
it was obviously the case that you know
india china all these places were just
going to develop in the way they have it
was not obviously the case it hadn't
happened before and i don't think we can
count on it having happened
if we if we had withdrawn from the world
as we had done uh in 1918 or as we had
done
uh uh
prior to 1914 in certain ways we
certainly couldn't count on its being
sustained
we had a pretty good liberal world order
until 1913 1914
but it turned out not to be
reliably enough
uh undergirded i think we have provided
a kind of ability to sustain that kind
of liberal world order that didn't exist
before and that is really
nothing to be not something to be taken
for granted and not something to be
whose importance
can be
slighted
intervention uh is messy they've been
good interventions in my opinion they've
been obviously ones that didn't go well
that were problematic and i think
they're vertically mixed they've been
ones that have
been mistaken the most uh the earliest
ones korean vietnam
were by far the most costly for us
korea may be necessary certainly part of
the outcome of that a very successful
booming free country
but not so happy a story obviously in
north korea at all vietnam a much
less successful obviously intervention
the subsequent ones one could go through
them and try to weigh them i'm sure
everyone's interested in iraq which i
was was a strong supporter of and
um remained a qualified i would say
supporter of obviously we were wrong
about weapons of mass destruction so
that's we would not have gone to war if
we had known they weren't there but
still i would say the the the
light in which we went to war in iraq
was for me at least personally i won't
speak to everyone else
the experience after the cold war of
said i'm invading kuwait and and just
you know killing
really hundreds of thousands of his own
people uh in the in the years before
that and and after the intervention when
we didn't go and remove him and insist
on regime change we let him hold power
kill people
redevelop some weapons of mass
destruction it turns out we destroyed a
lot of those in 1998 and then in the
balkans we did nothing as
milosevic
engaged in ethnic cleansing in europe
we finally intervened there and
reasonably successfully i would argue
and since then and 20 years for 20 years
since 98 99 after the second
intervention in kosovo
we have not had that kind of slaughter
in europe and we in fact achieved an
awful lot in
central and eastern europe where there
hadn't been much history too much
history of liberal democracy and freedom
some backsliding unfortunately in the
last few years and
especially in hungary and a little and
poland and that just for me makes the
case though why it's so important that
we stay engaged and stay active and nato
puts a lot of pressure on these
countries incidentally to
maintain their democracies a lot of
incentives for them not to slide back
uh the fact that we have
enemies like putin who've their
opponents like putin who've grown up
again for me makes the case for
that fundamental willingness to assume
our role in the world
uh not to try to pull back
i mean i would just say this about
interventions without you know trying to
escape
from the um difficulty of them
when i was very much younger someone
made the point that if the allies had
intervened if the uk and france had
intervened in 1936 when hitler went into
the sudetenland um
it would have been a total mess
and if they'd insist on a regime change
it would have been very difficult in
germany and people would be looking at
that two years later or maybe 15 years
later as gee was that really necessary
and that you know it's you've got to be
careful when you intervene you got to
step back let things play let things
take their course let things play out
you don't know what would have happened
if we hadn't done certain things
we do know what happened in syria when
we did not intervene in 2011 and then in
2013 with the red line
and we know that 500 000 people have
been killed and millions of people uh uh
driven from their homes a migration
crisis which then destabilized europe
incidentally and probably helped the
rise of authoritarian populism elsewhere
in the world so the intervention can
have bad consequences the war in iraq
was fought terribly for the first three
years and i i think we did stabilize it
by the end of 2008 with the surge but
i'm perfectly
open to the argument that all in all it
would have been better if we hadn't gone
in i think it's a it's hard to know you
can't rerun history backwards what would
it look like if saddam or his
kids were in charge and they were
developing weapons of mass destruction
as they had tried to in the past we
don't know but but i certainly will
acknowledge it was not a
well-run intervention and maybe not a
well-thought-through
intervention
still
you know syria is the counter-argument
of a non-intervention and i think one
has to take that counter-argument at
least
seriously people like me were very
influenced by the experience of the
balkans and i would say also by the
experience of rwanda in 94 where at that
point we were kind of exhausted we had
intervened in somalia in 93 that went
badly with mogadishu and we just
really neither party and almost no one
in the u.s said oh my god we can't just
sit back and watch what happened in
rwanda happened and a million people got
slaughtered and that was preventable
that was preventable by us and by others
and we didn't prevent it and i remember
six years later watching al gore and
george bush debate in 2000 on foreign
policy and the the anti-interventionist
move was still in the ascendancy uh
bush was chastising clinton for too uh
too aggressive a foreign policy he was
promising a more humble foreign policy
and one of the moderator jim lehrer said
well would you have intervened over what
a million people died there
wouldn't have taken that much to stop
that
or at least to stop some of that
and uh
bush said no no we can't just solve
everyone else's problems and gore who
certainly didn't agree with that i think
gore felt very bad that we hadn't
intervened said oh no we can't intervene
his political advisors have said there
was no support for intervention 911
changed that we went into afghanistan i
think correctly maybe we should have
maybe we should have left earlier maybe
we should at least sort of could have
done some things differently we they
went to iraq those are the two post-9 11
interventions really and again we don't
know what the world looks like
if we pull out of afghanistan earlier i
hope it doesn't go too terribly there
now i worry about what happens there in
terms of the people of afghanistan i
also worry what happens in terms of
regional
destabilization in pakistan uh and
elsewhere
pakistan's nuclear power i come back to
the nuclear question very few people
predicted in 1945 after hiroshima and
nagasaki that there would be no use of
nuclear weapons
for what what is it now 75 years
except for our tests
and
that's an achievement and who knows
whether we could have been less forward
leaning and stopped other nations from
getting nuclear weapons but the reason
japan is not a nuclear power is that we
there's a u.s japan defense pact and
defense pact means willingness to
intervene that's literally what a
defense pact means
and the reason south korea is not a
nuclear
power is probably that we have troops
there
as well as having
a pact with them
and if they both were looking at china
and there were no us troops in the
region and no u.s commitments they would
be nuclear and you have to then say what
does the world look like india and
pakistan nuclear weapons china does
that's dangerous enough south korea
japan do others decide i think we just
underestimate the cost that would be
paid if the u.s stepped back from
its global commitments
a couple of quick points in in closing
can we afford to be
the global superpower yes
it costs i don't know what our defense
budget is now about i think three and a
half four percent of gdp let's just add
a percent or two for intelligence state
department all the other costs of being
a global power
five six percent it's just not it's
worth it in my opinion if other people
think it's doing harm to the world
you can make that argument but it's not
it's not that we can't afford it
that is just not a real a really
important argument i think so we should
argue it on the merits i think rather
than this kind of notion that we're
going bankrupt because of the defense
budget
um is is the national security state
been terrible for us at home
uh has it you know eroded civil
liberties it's because it's sort of a
cliche that the national security state
the war is the health of the state and
and and you know it's very dangerous
to civil liberties
uh to freedom to uh civil rights
it can be and there's certainly
instances of that at the end of world
war one and that of course the japanese
internment for example in world war ii
but really the story from 45 to 2015 in
the u.s has been one of expanding
equality expanding civil liberties
certainly on core civil rights issues
for example
partly spurred in some respects by the
fact that we were telling the world they
had to be democratic and then people
correctly i mean the communists so that
said what about you look at the way uh
african-americans are treated in the u.s
and that was actually a bit of a spur to
improving our country it's not a reason
obviously to have the global
responsibilities but i think if you just
step back and say is there less you know
freedom of speech not a ton of issues we
care about freedom of religion it has
not been the case that at least the
post-1945 american global presence has
led to some kind of erosion of liberty
in the us we can argue about the size of
government in the u.s and all kinds of
issues but it's not just not empirically
true
that we've become some kind of garrison
state hostile to to freedom hostile to
social progress
and so forth
and finally i just think for those who
say well but all this is nice for the
world but what about america
american democracy american freedom is
not
solid is not i think ultimately
you can't count on it in a world that's
entirely hostile we have a big interest
in having other democracies in the world
for the sake of those people but also
for the sake of our own confidence in
ourselves and that we don't become a
garrison state constantly thinking that
all over the world there are
countries that might attack us so i
think even from the point of view of
democracy at home not even but including
not just from the point of view of
people living abroad but from the point
of view of americans at home
we have a big interest
in democracy around the world
thank you bill
[Applause]
for the negative scott horton take it
away scott
all right thank you gene
and hello to mr crystal
as some of you know mr crystal was chief
of staff to dan quayle who i consider to
be the best vice president of my
lifetime
and think about who the other ones were
for a second
i will respond about hitler and world
war ii more in a later segment there
america is in real trouble
for the last few years my opponent has
been at the forefront of those warning
against the death of modern liberalism
and that far-right populist trumpism is
taking this country in a very dangerous
direction
towards authoritarianism even
dictatorship
but mr crystal you and david brooks
promised us national greatness
you said america needed to be called to
their quote grand destiny
quote nationalism
we needed quote national strength and
moral assertiveness abroad advancing the
cause of freedom around the world
we needed a big project we could all do
together
as brooke's friend christopher beam
wrote invading iraq what suited his
quest and yours for this greatness
in his 1996 article toward a
neo-reaganite foreign policy arguing for
benevolent global hegemony my opponent
wrote that john quincy adams was wrong
that the u.s should not go abroad
seeking monsters to destroy
why not he asked
for the exact reasons that quincy adams
delineated our principles would turn
from liberty to force we would become
the dicatrists of the world but no
longer the ruler of our own spirit he
said
adams was right
the wars did not make america great
the wars
three thousand people were killed on
september 11 2001.
as paul wolfowitz admitted the main
reason osama bin laden cited for
attacking america was the u.s military
bases left in saudi arabia for the
so-called dual containment policy
against iraq and iran in the 1990s after
iraq war one the persian gulf war
bin laden's plan was to provoke the
united states into invading afghanistan
so he could replicate the mujahideen's
earlier success against the ussr with
u.s support in the 1980s this time
against us
to bog us down bleed us to bankruptcy
and create a choking life for the
american people under the tyranny of our
security state
and after the last 20 years of war in
afghanistan and across the middle east
we have less influence there than ever
before
a 30 trillion dollar national debt
an increasingly invasive surveillance
state and militarized police state
almost seven thousand dead troops
thirty seven 000 if you count those who
killed themselves in the aftermath
and the worst partisan political racial
and other social division of my lifetime
anyway
i'm 45.
so much of this crisis is directly due
to the costs financial and otherwise of
america's middle east regime change wars
let's review some recent regime changes
and their consequences
note
that in neoconservative doctrine
democracy absolutely must be spread to
afghanistan iran iraq libya and syria
but not saudi arabia bahrain qatar
kuwait uae oman egypt or pakistan
and if there's a democratically elected
government that our government doesn't
like the us won't hesitate to try to
overthrow it like in algeria 1993 gaza
in 2007 egypt in 2013 and ukraine in
2004 and 2014.
now to the regime changes i'm sorry i
have to skip kosovo and somalia for time
first on our list is president carter
and reagan's support for the mujahideen
in afghanistan in the 1980s to overthrow
the communist regime there this led
directly to the rise of haqqani
hekmatyar the taliban and al-qaeda
carter and reagan's support for saddam
hussein's iraq and its 1980s war to
overthrow the ayatollah in iran also
backfired it solidified the mullah's
power in persia and led directly to the
so-called gulf war after iraq invaded
kuwait in a dispute over debts from the
war against iran
as mentioned america's first iraq war
launched to restore the kuwaiti monarchy
in 1991 led directly to the dual
containment policy against iraq and iran
from military bases in saudi arabia and
al qaeda's war against the united states
since
2001 after failing to deploy enough
reinforcements to capture or kill bin
laden at tora bora or allow the delta
force to produ to pursue him into
pakistan the bush administration instead
sought regime change against the taliban
in kabul who bill clinton had supported
just a few years before in their own
regime change against the mujahideen
warlords whom presidents carter and
reagan had supported against the
communists in the 1980s
this led to 20 years of war
including a massive so-called surge
escalation halfway through for
absolutely nothing and leading to the
taliban walking right back into power as
the u.s withdrew in the summer of 2021.
saddam hussein in iraq war ii
when david wormser wrote his clean break
plan for israeli prime minister benjamin
netanyahu's first government in 1996 he
acknowledged that targeting secularist
dictators hussein and assad for regime
change in iraq and syria could further
fan the flames of islamist anti-american
terrorism
but he said the solution to that problem
would just have to wait until the war
against them was over
maybe in 1996 this was somehow
understandable from a hawks perspective
at least
according to richard schultz in the
weekly standard in the 1990s the
pentagon joint staff would repeat as
cliche that quote terrorism is a small
price to pay for being a superpower
but after the african embassy bombings
of 1998 the uss cole attack in 2000 and
september 11th which killed nearly 3 000
people in new york and at the pentagon
it was
less understandable
yet the neoconservatives led by mr
crystal persisted
the neocons best laid plans to empower
jordan and compliant shiites to take
over iraq failed
the american invasion of 2003 empowered
iran's favored factions among the
shiites the supreme islamic council and
dawa party
in fact it was king abdullah of jordan
who coined the phrase shiite crescent to
describe iran's newly enhanced power
just after the invasion
clean break nothing
this american shiite alliance pushed
their sunni arab enemies out of baghdad
and into the arms of al-qaeda in iraq
which did not even exist before the war
adding thousands of hardened fighters to
osama bin laden's movement including
thousands of foreign fighters who
traveled there to fight against the u.s
shiite alliance
many of these men later went home to
libya syria and yemen to get ready for
the next wars there
the u.s took their side in all three
in libya the hawks said they had to
intervene to overthrow secular dictator
gaddafi to protect the poor civilians
but at the very least tens of thousands
of people have been killed in endless
fighting in that country in the decades
since
bin ladenite groups veterans of the
second iraq war led that revolt and have
thrived in the meantime as civil war has
raged for years
some warlords brought back literal
chattel slavery of sub-saharan africans
thousands of refugees drown in the
mediterranean
the war spread from libya into mali chad
niger sierra leone burkina faso and
nigeria
obama's an allied support for the bin
ladenite revolt against the secular
government in syria an attempt to weaken
their ally iran after the iraq war had
done so much to empower them led to the
rise of the islamic state so-called
caliphate in eastern syria and western
iraq and then the third iraq war from
2014 to 2018 to then destroy it on
behalf of those same iranian-backed
shiite groups the hawks wish they hadn't
fought the second iraq war for
no the u.s should not back these
dictators like so-called president sisi
in egypt that's part of what got us
attacked in the first place but we sure
as hell should not be supporting bin
ladenite insurgencies against them
either
hillary clinton and saudi arabia's
installation of mansur hadi when they
co-opted the arab spring revolt in yemen
in 2011 and 12 led straight to the next
phase of the war which broke out in
2015.
for the last six and a half years the us
has backed saudi arabia and uae in a war
that has killed hundreds of thousands of
people and also strengthened al qaeda in
the arabian peninsula beyond belief
there are now something like thirty
thousand bin laden night fighters in the
world and iran and russia who intervened
to save assad from al-qaeda and isis are
more influential in the region than ever
this is not how it was supposed to be
speaking of russia it isn't just the
mideast wars in georgia the u.s
supported the rose revolution of 2003
and the installation of mikhail
shakashvili who almost got us into a war
with russia when he attacked their
peacekeeping forces in south ossetia
just five years later and vice president
cheney urged george bush to strike
russian forces coming across the
caucasus mountains
the u.s also helped to overthrow the
government of ukraine twice in 2004 and
2014.
in 2014 they used actual nazis in a
street push against the elected
government
it was supposed to be easy to get away
with while putin was distracted with the
sochi olympics but instead the new
ukraine ku junta lost crimea to russia
and started a brutal war in the east
which has killed more than ten thousand
people and unnecessarily ratcheted up
tensions with the other most powerful
nuclear weapons state on the planet then
national endowment for democracy head
carl gershman even threatened regime
change in moscow itself in the
washington post in october 2013.
secretary of state hillary clinton
famously blessed the honduran coup of
2009 leading directly to the rise of
murderous drug cartels in that country
and a massive child refugee crisis at
our southern border
the american establishment had its
so-called unipolar moment at the high
water mark of us influence to lead the
world into the brave new future at the
turn of the millennium
and they blew it
the u.s government has spread not
liberty but the tyranny of the majority
not free markets but corrupt crony
contracting
not peace and security but mass
sectarian violence and destabilization
this has led to increased support for
left and right wing socialism around the
world in reaction
liberalism and democracy in the broadest
sense have been discredited as meaning
nothing more than supplication to
american demands or cheap excuses for
our violent intervention
the economic crisis and refugee crisis
resulting from our middle east wars has
led to the rise of the populist right in
europe where they are ascendant in the
european parliament the uk has left the
eu and the unraveling of the entire
so-called liberal international order
even in the west has begun
in your 1997 national greatness piece in
the wall street journal you wrote that
the universal principle at the heart of
the american ideal is a mandate to quote
advance freedom and quote around the
world
apparently by any means necessary for
the world's own good
but means determine ends
and even if somehow waging violent coups
and regime change wars across the planet
could guarantee freedom for those people
it would necessarily come at the expense
of those whose lives and liberty our
government is actually sworn to protect
ours
no wonder that here in america as well
people are moving to the socialist left
and nationalist right since the
disastrous consequences of militarism
and regime change are what passes for
liberalism in the center
the backlash from bush's disastrous wars
and the devastating economic crash of
2008 a direct result of the fed's
militarism-friendly easy money policy in
the preceding decade
led to the disruptive and destabilizing
presidency of barack obama
his disastrous wars and the so-called
k-shaped economic recovery of his time
in office meaning bankers and think
tankers paid by defense contractors did
great while the people on the bottom
three quarters of the economic ladder
remained stuck in 2009
led directly to the election of donald j
trump running as an economic populist
and war skeptic over w bush's brother
and barack obama's secretary of state
his election was a reaction against the
military and economic legacy of the
preceding 15 years and its central
liberal liberal establishment champions
including the neoconservatives
and who
a guy who built his political capital
proclaiming on talk radio that obama was
a secret pro-terrorist muslim from kenya
in other words your nemesis trump was
exploiting your movement's previous
cultivation of this sort of ill-liberal
sentiment among republican voters back
when it was still useful to your ends
building support for the wars
now that the anti-muslim chauvinism of
the american right is no longer useful
you claim the right itself is now the
greatest threat to democracy
if so this is the nationalist movement
the neoconservatives have done so much
to cultivate and promote
for bin laden and his friends were few
but would-be enemies who happened to be
muslim were many
so bush and the neocons supported the
worst sort of right-wing populist
nationalism in america especially with
their wink and not approach to the
muslim-hating hacks on am talk radio it
was central to karl rove's plan for his
permanent republican majority
that was a big part of why my opponent
was so determined to bring sarah palin
on board with john mccain in 2008 she
could get the rubes excited and and
afraid and keep them and contin and
convince them to continue to support the
mccainian neoconservative doctrines
behind the long war in the middle east
it's why your friend frank gaffney
pretended to believe that a small sufi
mosque in a building down the street
from the old world trade center site was
supposed to represent the muslim enemy's
triumph over america or that the 50
states needed to pass emergency
legislation to protect us all from
enslavement under sharia law
this deliberately deceptive campaign did
much to make the right worse
now the centrists are terrified of the
populist right accusing them all being
neo-nazi white supremacists including
many tens or hundreds of thousands of
men and women who are resentful veterans
of the wars you lied them into
and in turn the populist right is
terrified that the war on terrorism is
now being turned against them as the
department of homeland security
redefines violent extremism to mean
almost any political activity outside of
the two major parties the people in
return resent the power of the
establishment which so despises them
even more
and now the average guy is supposed to
believe that the last quarter century's
greatest proponents of american empire
such as mr crystal and dick cheney's
daughter liz herself an avowed hawk and
promoter of torture are the last
principal defenders of the old republic
they destroyed
who's buying that
engagement leadership
primacy preeminence hegemony these are
just euphemisms for world empire with
the usa and the position of the hated
british that our forebears had led the
world in overthrowing the doctrine that
the middle part of north america should
be or could be the dominant military and
political power in eurasia and
indefinitely is crazy on its face
and plus the whole thing is really just
a racket as the soldiers call it a
self-licking ice cream cone
in other words a government program
creating its own disasters it must then
attempt to solve
no nation on earth threatens the united
states
as ron paul once told the washington
post we could defend this country with a
couple of good submarines
the u.s constitution does not authorize
this posture of global dominance the
people of the world do not want it the
american people's costs are in the
trillions and our gain is non-existent
we suffer the terribly destructive
inflation generated boom bust cycle and
endlessly rising prices
the feds rifle through our internet and
phone records our sheriff's deputies act
like special operations forces at war in
our neighborhoods time's up scott good
yeah good night one more second go again
one more second sorry i'm almost done oh
well um
our sheriff's deputies
act like special operations forces at
war in our neighborhoods our soldiers
and marines come home maimed physically
and mentally and more and more
terrorists are motivated to attack the
united states there's a widespread
feeling in america that liberty justice
fairness under law and cooperation and
compromise through little d democracy is
now untenable
hatreds between sectors of society have
become much more solidified more people
speak of secession and separation the
people are finding out the hard way that
you cannot have it both ways there is no
such thing as a limited constitutional
world empire there cannot be a balanced
budget a free and prosperous economy
independent major media or rule of law
in a state of permanent war
we americans i'm almost done give me
just a sec we americans are losing our
freedom in the name of forcibly
spreading it to the rest of the world
enough already let's defend america
first and all aggressive wars and covert
interventions in other nations abandon
our empire and put the protection of
liberty in our own country at the top of
our political priorities then shed of
all this violent hypocrisy we will be
able to lead the world in the only
legitimate way we can
by the benign sympathy of our example
thank you um okay
and sorry for going over here
[Applause]
uh
bill crystal you get an extra two
minutes for your rebuttal um but you
want you you can take this podium for
your rebuttal maybe best
yeah okay
take it away bill
kind of a lot to rub out there but i
will uh
that's okay i think i'll just i'll just
let the two minutes go um
i you know
the middle east is a very difficult part
of the world and we've obviously made
many mistakes there i think one of the
mistakes we made was not pushing
democracy hard enough when we had real
leverage
i'm not a defender of the saudi regime i
was kind of mocked in 2002 when i said
that i thought a consistent policy for
freedom in that part of the world would
would anticipate and even work towards
the end of the dominance of the house of
saud in in saudi arabia and i continue
to think and i was certainly critical of
both the trump and biden administration
for being too soft on mbs for example
for arranging for the killing of an
american resident jamal khashoggi so
i've been same with sisi same with
pakistan i i would be
if anything i think in the middle east
which is so difficult though and which
we look at and then get
understandably
uh shrink from the consequences of
really a kind of even liberal imperial
world and so we tend to pull back and we
tend to
for understandable reasons
prioritize short-term security uh peace
anti-terror which is awfully important
you know it's not nothing that we
haven't had another 9 11 in 20 years um
and uh and we probably don't do enough
to promote liberty and democracy
mr horton didn't seem to acknowledge the
importance of the u.s uh
commitments in europe and in asia
to defending democracies where they
exist or creating them where they didn't
exist to expanding them where they exist
and to the general peace and prosperity
of both regions which is not something
that had marked them historically for
the preceding part of the 20th century
when we weren't involved
much
we have it's not as if we've never not
been involved in the world we've not
been involved in the world and very
conspicuously chose not to be involved
in the world after 1918 and we saw how
that worked out now maybe that's not
it's not the same and we could have done
things differently and it wasn't
inevitable that what happened in both
asia and europe were to happen
but
i think one at least has to somehow
sketch out
how our withdrawal from the world would
not invite
a much greater aggression on the part of
autocrats much greater oppression at
home
on the part of dictators totally
unfettered by any fear of u.s pressure
u.s sanctions u.s
soft power let alone u.s hard power um
so i i really think that's a very
that would be a very bad world
uh at the end mr horton tried to sort of
say well he's sort of vaguely for
liberty around the world too
but actually this it wouldn't be good
for liberty around the world i don't
believe would be good for liberty here i
know for the reasons i i briefly
indicated
this i do believe that it's not well
i'll put it this way the people who care
a lot about liberty in the us really
care about liberty
uh seem to be mostly to be people who
also care about liberty around the world
they could differ somewhat on how much
we can do whether as joe biden thinks we
should withdraw from afghanistan and use
more diplomacy and hopefully not have to
fight middle east type wars i'm
uncertain about that future
uh i agree with him on the other hand to
maintaining the alliances in europe and
asia but i would make this point
talk to actual liberals
small liberals people who believe in
liberty around the world talk to actual
democrats around the world how many of
them want the u.s to withdraw even the
ones who think the u.s has been unwise
in their countries and i've discussed
this with many such people
often in the middle east in pakistan and
saudi arabia don't think the answer is
well if you just left things would
really get better quite the contrary
it's that we're not doing the right
thing we're not doing things carefully
enough we're not being uh
intelligent enough in the way in which
we promote liberty those are all fair
points and we'll but
the idea that somehow any people real
people around the world whether it's and
i was i thought it was unfortunate that
mr horton repeated in effect pro putin
talking points about ukraine um
i sympathize with the ukrainian people
who were invaded by putin's russia and
and the idea that putin wouldn't do more
if the nato and the fact ukraine was
kept outside the nato guarantees gave up
its weapons as nuclear weapons in 94
great victory incidentally for nuclear
non-proliferation because we in the
britain and britain
kind of guaranteed ukraine they wouldn't
pay a price for giving up those weapons
they were nervous about russia even then
we didn't do much when russia invaded we
at least were able to contain it to a
little to a part of ukraine but again
the the evidence for me is that it's u.s
retreat that invites aggression not
excessive u.s intervention that invites
aggression or that makes life more
miserable for more people again
interventions individually we can debate
how to do what we can debate
wars haven't gone away because of the us
maintain global order the middle east in
particular is a very difficult part of
the world where the transition to
modernity has been very problematic in
so many ways uh and maybe we should have
been more cautious in the middle east
about what we could do though again i
would just point out the places where we
have there's been a unbelievable amount
of slaughter in the middle east that we
weren't involved in one way or the other
uh when thanks to the iran iraq war
where the sophisticated
establishment types in washington were
sort of let them just kill each other
that actually didn't work out well and
also hundreds of thousands of people
died and syria the refugee crisis is a
product of non-intervention in syria
not doing what obama said would do the
use of chemical weapons against the
syrian people has not been assad has
paid no price for that and he's still in
power and that's a horrible
signal to send a horrible precedent to
allow to be set in the 21st century so i
i unapologetic and defending
uh
leave aside my i guess i could defend my
1997 piece but i don't really remember
it that well except the national
greatness we were for was a greatness in
defending and promoting freedom and i am
for that kind of national greatness i am
for a healthy debate in our free
democracy about how to do that i am not
for trump type national greatness which
cares not at all about political and
civil liberties
[Applause]
five minutes everybody from you scott
take it away okay and sorry for going
over before when i practiced i read it
fast i guess
uh all right few things here in no
particular order but you know first of
all the second world war obviously hangs
over all of this america defeated
uh the nazis and the japanese and then
you know created this post-war order uh
that uh mr crystal's referring to here
uh but the thing of that is
as you guys all
i'm sorry
as i think everybody knows as even
winston churchill himself said
it was theodore roosevelt and especially
woodrow wilson's intervention in world
war one that caused world war ii world
war one was ending as a stalemate before
america got involved and tilted the
powers so far in favor of the allies and
against the central powers that first of
all they prolonged the world long enough
for lenin and trotsky no offense to uh
cease power in russia and create the
soviet union
and they
empowered the british and the french to
inflict the versailles treaty on the
germans which stripped them of all of
their territories and demanded all these
reparations that destroyed the economy
and led to the rise of the nazi power uh
the nazi party uh on the promise of
getting revenge for what had been done
to the germans at the end of world war
one if america had just stayed out there
would have been no soviet union and no
nazi germany to fight world war ii at
all okay
um then
uh as far as what happened in ukraine in
2014
america sponsored
real nazis not just neo-nazis but the
proud grandsons of the galatian ss who
had perpetrated the holocaust in ukraine
against jews and pulse there
the right sector this faboda party
formerly called the social nationalist
party and the azov battalion all of whom
proudly fly swastikas and
commit crimes against minorities in
ukraine and it was ukraine that attacked
the east once they overthrew the
government
the
donbass region in the east of the
country donetsk and luhansk they decided
well if you guys are going to overthrow
the government we elected in a free and
fair election in 2010 then we're just
going to occupy all the government
buildings and refused to recognize the
new government then the kiev regime
attacked them they called it the war on
terrorism and they invaded the eastern
part of their own country and yes it's
true that the russians did send special
operations forces across the border to
help them but they never did invade the
country at all with regular infantry and
when in 2000 and i think late 14 or
early 2015 the people of the donbass
region voted in a plebiscite to join the
russian federation putin told them no he
had no interest in absorbing their
territory whatsoever he would only
provide them enough help that they
needed to keep the kiev regime out and
that was it you also heard and this goes
back to his original statement
at the beginning here that the u.s has
kept the peace
in the world for 75 years
and he did mention korea and vietnam and
that's all
but he didn't mention that we killed two
million koreans
somewhere between three and five million
nobody really knows how many vietnamese
laotians and cambodians were killed and
then of course the domino fell it was
knocked over by america and spread
communism to cambodia and led directly
to the rise of pol pot and another 2
million dead there he didn't count the
million dead iraqis or the million dead
and oh i got to talk about obama's
intervention in syria he didn't talk
about the million dead iraqis the half a
million dead syrians and and pakistanis
and afghans and libyans and now yemenis
where at the very minimum a quarter of a
million people have been killed uh you
know certainly in the war in somalia
which helped lead to the famine of 2011
through 13 something like 250 000 people
died in that famine muslim children
under the age of five just like who's
dying of cholera in the war in yemen
inflicted by the americans and their
allies who bombed the hospitals bombed
the water and the sewage and the
electricity and all of the means of
civilian support there in that country
and now it's just not true and i don't
know who told you this but you might
know that edward snowden leads the black
budget to the washington post and they
published it obama spent a billion
dollars a year on the war in syria and
he admitted it jeffrey goldberg asked
him in march of 2012. he said don't you
think that if we got rid of assad in
syria that'd be a good way to bring iran
down a peg and obama said absolutely
and goldberg said well is there anything
more that you could be doing to speed
this process along and obama said well i
can't tell you jeffrey because your
classified clearance isn't high enough
and we all know because even the
washington post and the new york times
admitted it over and over america saudi
qatar
uh turkey jordan and israel all
supported al-nusrah which and their uh
allies jaishol islam and the other bin
ladenite groups there these were the
syrian veterans of iraq war ii and
america took their side because the
government that they were fighting was
friends with iran which had no role in
knocking our towers down time's up
well thank you for both we now go to the
q and a portion of the evening we have
two mikes over there you can line up
to ask your questions
and we have questions uh from the
streamers uh i wanna take my moderator's
prerogative to ask a question uh
of scott uh i believe a bill crystal has
basically asked you for a counter
factual and
and of course you guys are sometimes
talking about more than a century's
worth of military foreign policy
i'm wondering scott if you could take it
from 9 11. like there was a question 9
11 happened
let's assume that
everything up through 9 11 also happened
you didn't change that part of history
but now from 9 11 on
bill is really challenging you to say
what is your alternative
to what went on what what could have
happened from 9 11 on what well i'll
cite the great harry brown the former
libertarian presidential candidate and
great libertarian activist i i asked him
on my show harry brown did you hear me
the first part yeah the great harry
brown i asked him well what would you
have done
and he would have called off the
policies that called the cause the
attack in the first place but assuming
the attack what he would have done was
he would have negotiated in good faith
with the taliban who hated bin laden and
al-qaeda and wanted rid of him instead
of refusing the taliban's offers to
negotiate as george bush did for almost
a solid month in the lead-up to the
start of the war
and barring that uh barring success on
negotiating extradition he would have
sent special operations forces to
capture or kill bin laden and his few
hundreds no more than 400
members of al qaeda they're hiding with
bin laden at tora bora in afghanistan
and then he would have called the whole
thing off and especially including the
entire policy of american dominance in
the middle east
that was the cause of the problem in the
first place our bases in saudi our
support for israel and their unending
violence against the people of palestine
and at that time of lebanon and
if we had just called all of that off
and proved to the world that we are what
the statue of liberty says that we are
and that was harry brown's thing the
statue of liberty and if we had
you know really worked hard to perfect
liberty in our own country and to spread
it by example and in fact harry brown
was an evangelical uh libertarian he was
determined to see liberty spread around
the world and he was determined to give
his statue a liberty speech he would
have given it every day if he'd been the
president about how we are doing
everything we can to perfect the
application of the bill of rights in our
society and your societies out there in
the world your bills of rights aren't
good enough and you need to try at least
as hard as we are trying to create a
free society for our own people here and
then instead of waiting in a swimming
pool of the blood of innocent people
looking like the world's worst hypocrite
it would have been great and it would
have sounded great to the people of the
world remember on september 12th
they held a million-man candlelight
vigil in downtown tehran
on behalf of the people of the united
states
we had the entire world ready to listen
to america ready to join up in our cause
but it wasn't the right cause
it was hey you know what we could do we
could get a bonus war if we could just
lie to these people and we'll just
publish in the weekly standard over and
over and over again that osama bin laden
and saddam hussein are friends and
saddam's going to give weapons of mass
destruction to osama bin laden to kill
you and your mama and your hometown if
we don't pre-empt them and stop them
from attacking us first let's do that we
could get away with that people are so
upset about the 3 000 dead new yorkers
we could exploit that grief and fear
we could overthrow whoever we want now
on to baghdad against who the guy in the
french beret
and the clean shaven chin and the olive
green military uniform who
they could have just sent
colin powell the secretary of state at
the time was a four-star general former
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff i
think he was tough enough to handle
saddam
and if not him how about mean old donald
rumsfeld they were old friends from when
he helped arm iraq in the 1980s under
ronald reagan they couldn't have just
gone over there and read the riot act to
saddam and put him in line no remember
dick cheney said we can't talk to evil
because that will
you know justify it and that will you
know saddam hussein like he wasn't
already the dictator of iraq since 1979
that will give him legitimacy and
credibility if we talk to him we have
only one choice
to attack iraq before they attack us
first see aha
bill uh please take the mic up and um
do you want to comment on scott swiss
reply our policies did not cause 911 our
policies did not cause
assad to use poison gas against his own
people and kill 500 000 of them our
policies did not cause putin to kill
journalists and to crush freedom in
russia
i mean mr horton may believe that the
u.s is the source and cause of evil in
the world i disagree
um okay um do you well i know if you
want to have another dialogue about that
briefly go ahead yeah and then
well the men who did 911 were
responsible for 9 11 but they were
motivated by american foreign policy
and you know i actually just went back
and watched the cnn interview of bin
laden from 1998
or 96
and the whole story is well they hate
our bases in saudi arabia and our
support for israel back to you in the
studio jimmy
because nobody said they hate us for our
freedom they hate us because their
radical islamic beliefs make them hate
those who are good and innocent and
beautiful and love their mama no one had
told that lie yet
something
simple
you think the taliban are doing what
they're doing right now in in
afghanistan because they hate what do
they hate we got out of afghanistan
well the taliban aren't attacking us i
don't know what you're talking about
they were attacking us until we left and
then they stopped i'm saying do you
think that there's going to be liberty
and freedom that young girls in
afghanistan will have opportunities and
the like
no
okay i don't know what the point is well
the point of that is that liberty
matters around the world that bin laden
was not provoked by i don't believe
our having some bases in saudi arabia
that we'd had for an awful long time or
by our supporting israel which had been
there for an awful lot you don't believe
that because you don't know anything
about it i guess why don't you read the
declaration of war from 1996 and 1998 or
you know what better yet read perfect
soldiers by terry mcdermott it's the
biography of the hamburg cell 911
hijackers don't interrupt yet hang on a
second mohammed atta
the lead hijacker on september 11th
he joined al qaeda decided to join
al-qaeda and attack the united states
when israel invaded lebanon in 1996 in
operation grapes of wrath and a couple
of months later osama bin laden put out
his declaration of war
declaring war against the united states
and ranting on and on about the kana
massacre of a hundred and six dead
civilians killed by the israelis hiding
in a u.n shelter and that was when
muhammad atta and his friend ramsay bin
al-sheeb decided they wanted to join al
qaeda they then went and traveled to
afghanistan met bin laden joined the
group and were recruited to carry out
the planes operation against the united
states of america so
even if you want to pretend to believe
that all bin laden cared about was that
we didn't all want to convert to his
religion or something else his
recruitment shtick
was these people are hurting our people
simple as that
there have always been injustices in the
world which allow evil men
to recruit others to work to serve them
i mean obviously hitler took advantage
of versailles i think again that was us
stepping back incidentally in 1919 not
imposing something on as much as maybe
we should have to make sure there was
more just peace the fact that evil men
take advantage of
past injustices grievances
uh insoluble conflicts does not mean
that we then what withdraw and hope that
those evil men do nothing evil it means
we should stop doing evil and terrible
things that provoke them we did well
that's ridiculous that's where i'm just
okay fine i'm just gonna say i do not
believe that we did evil things that
provoked 9 11.
okay uh thank you both that was a good
and lively exchange and
and now we are going to put it over to
questions please please don't identify
yourself just ask your question as a
question
if you want to address it to one of the
other party say so but otherwise ask the
question please take it away sir
uh my question is for mr bill crystal um
clearly american foreign policy is in
the great pivot to china
you know we have two major fighter jets
being designed right now with china in
mind we have aircraft carriers being
designed with china in mind
right now we sail pretty often
our nimitz class carrier into area that
china considers their their waters
and there's six thousand souls on board
those nimitz-class carriers and china
has missiles that can strike them
if we were to lose one carrier that'd be
six thousand dead that's that's two nine
elevens in one afternoon
what would be our response if if in in
current american foreign policy and
wouldn't that response
wouldn't one of the things on the table
be a nuclear exchange and at that point
aren't we you know playing rolling the
dice on the great sword of damocles over
us thank you for your question bill
yeah
i mean china is a big challenge to the
u.s it's very unfortunate that the bet
on liberalization in china which was not
a crazy bet that economic involvement
would encourage political liberalization
may have worked for a while has now been
reversed by xi
we have defense obligations obviously to
japan taiwan and elsewhere
and i do think in general those aircraft
carriers have maintained the peace and i
mean just empirically they have
maintained the peace i would argue in an
area of the world where there are deep
enmities and where there have been
terrible terrible wars
in not quite in our memory but in the
memory of our parents and grandparents
if we were to withdraw out of fear and
it's an understandable concern obviously
that let's say there would be a chinese
missile attack on on one of our carriers
um i mean i think we can deter that
without using nuclear weapons or even
threatening the use of nuclear weapons
but if we were to withdraw we would have
i mean japan would certainly go nuclear
other countries in the region south
korea i think even taiwan if they had a
chance would decide there's no
u.s
defense
australia the u.s defense commitments
have no credibility and that creates a
much more dangerous and much more
unstable world i mean if you want to
create a world that has the conditions
that then leads to an endless cycle of
violence i would say
the u.s can just withdraw from asia we
can withdraw from europe we can give up
on our efforts in the middle east and we
will have endless cycles of violence as
we've had in so many
in those parts of the world before
over the in the 21st century
comment scott
well it doesn't make any difference one
way or the other to the american people
who rules taiwan
nobody wants to see violence it would be
terrible if china invaded and people
were killed there no one wants that but
if the chinese rolled into outer
mongolia
does anybody in here think that america
should intervene
start a war to protect mongolia from
chinese aggression
or there's some things that are just out
of our purview and out of our
jurisdiction
and cost too much and by the way you
know back to the cost mr crystal has
said
repeatedly just how affordable
all of this is but our national debt is
30 trillion dollars right now we spend
something like a trillion dollars a year
on militarism if you count the va and
the care and feeding of the nukes at the
energy department and the rest of that
we absolutely cannot afford it and if
you ask the people who lost uh you know
uh people in the wars or in the
terrorist attacks against this country
in the meantime their costs are a lot
higher now you know
if you have a think tank that's financed
by arms manufacturers then
these are good times and you don't
probably understand what anybody else
has to worry about but there is severe
as they call it economic anxiety in this
country mostly caused by the boom and
bust crash
cycle that we have the they call it the
business cycle it's the inflationary
money cycle and the reason they keep
expanding the money supply is to make
the world empire seemed free
for all those checks he was cashing they
never raised his taxes once in the
highest bracket
because they just borrowed the money
from china and printed it instead
so then regular people are blowing their
brains out because they're forced to
carry this economy on their back
okay next question over there please
no no
my question goes to mr crystal recently
you wrote in an article at the bulwark
commenting on some of biden's comments
around afghanistan recently quote biden
concludes his anti-war discussion by
reminding us that there's nothing low
grade or low risk or low cost about any
war but this isn't true
hard-hearted though it may sound to say
this some wars are much more low grade
or low risk or low cost than others so
first mr crystal could you define a
little more specifically what you view
as low grade low risk and low cost and
then point to a specific intervention
say in the last couple or few decades
that you view as meeting that criteria
and having been successful
yeah i think the balkans intervention i
would say and obviously i mean look i
am anti-war i hate the idea that we
would send and most americans do the
idea that americans are yearning to send
young men and women abroad to fight
that's not the case if anything it's the
opposite we're large commercial country
we we we enjoy
and as we should pursuing happiness here
in the united states we're cerrets we
have oceans protecting us
we don't have a long historical
tradition uh as maybe we have some
tradition of course of fighting on this
continent um not always justly obviously
but we don't have the kind of european
type history and so americans i think on
the whole refrain from wars
and it is good to have an american
president honestly and i think almost
every american president falls into this
category who is reluctant to
send young americans off to war but if
you think as i do that's occasionally
the threat of war and even more
occasionally less occasionally i guess i
should say
war actually engaging war is necessary
then you have to
obviously try to confine them to less uh
costly wars both economically and much
more importantly in terms of the human
cost and importantly also in terms of
the after effects the the sort of what
what what messages get sent so i would
say the balkans would be
one case of a
war that was uh worth it and that i
think had pretty good consequences uh in
europe and i would compare it to the
convention in a place like rwanda or
syria
scott comment
yeah uh you know as yugoslavia was
breaking up
they actually had struck a deal where
the bosnian muslims and the croats would
have a coalition and they would be the
majority
and the serbs would be the minority
partner in the coalition
and they signed on to that and accepted
that
it wasn't until american ambassador
zimmerman intervened and told the croats
to not take the deal to ruin the deal
they'd already accepted and instead go
to war you can have more and that was
what turned the you know disas what was
already a disaster in the balkans into
the absolute catastrophe um that you
know he's claiming that america solved
it was the american ambassador who
helped to cause that thing in the first
place
and and you know i'm sorry i meant to
mention earlier real quick here when i
was talking about the 2 million dead in
korea and the 3 million in vietnam and
the million and a half or two killed in
america's middle east wars just in the
last 20 years the people who always get
left out of that are the people of
indonesia and east timor and bangladesh
and
guatemala of course 500 000 dead in the
civil war caused by the american coup in
guatemala
and of course el salvador and nicaragua
all throughout the middle east and these
are essentially massacres and and you
know pseudogenocides uh even in some
cases perpetrated by american puppets
american compliant governments and
governments protected by the united
states of america for example
gerald ford gave the green light for the
massacre of the east timorese in
indonesia in 1975. richard nixon gave
the green light for the pakistanis to
carry out their atrocities in bangladesh
and etc etc
he always says not just tonight but
always america has kept the peace for 75
years
our only white lives important
does it only matter that russia hasn't
fought
germany again
and these other people's lives just
don't count the usa has killed a
holocaust worth of civilians okay let's
summarize it there's got five years
let's summarize it there uh next
question
yeah
oh uh sorry a hypothetical question for
you mr horton
let's say you are the resident of a
totalitarian nation like australia
and let's say let's say 10 20 years pass
they're still locked down the rest of
the world is back to normal they'll
they're they are still under lockdowns
you live in australia would you want
american
would you like america to intervene to
come say you save you in totalitarian
australia
no absolutely i would not want that and
especially looking at the consequences
of american intervention there but you
know i think there's going to be a very
strong reaction in australia and they
are under an absolutely authoritarian
lockdown system right now but they still
have regular elections
and at least for now i guess we'll see
but uh i am predicting the resounding
defeat of everybody in charge of that
country now after they have pushed uh
things so far and but one more thing too
if americans individual citizens want to
go overseas and participate in somebody
else's conflict like the spanish civil
war
or you want to go and help liberate uh
the people and you know the iraqis
enslaved under the dhaba party now then
you're free to go and do that
just leave me out of it thank you bill
do you have a comment on australia
i'm going to have a comment on a
discourse that you know trivializes the
holocaust by saying the united states
has conducted holocaust that attacks
that demeans the united states in really
grotesque way if we made mistakes did we
give as you say green lights or yellow
lights when we shouldn't have that could
quite well that could be talk to people
from east team war though talk to people
from bangladesh do they want the u.s to
just withdraw and leave them leave them
to the mercies of their neighbors or
would they prefer for the u.s to have
done more and to be doing more and as we
have done more since incidentally uh the
pakistan bangladesh split off from
pakistan doing more to keep the peace
there talk to people who care about
liberty around the world they understand
that for all the mistakes we make
and that we are important to them to
their peace to their prosperity to their
liberty people of all colors i would say
all that's the cities all religions of
course our dimension of the balkans was
on behalf of muslims our intervention in
iraq and afghanistan was on behalf of
muslims and our departure from
afghanistan has unfortunately left many
decent people in afghanistan who worked
with us but more importantly worked for
themselves and enjoyed the relative
freedom of the last 20 years now
worrying that they may never have a
chance at that again i hope we can do it
diplomatically
help get decent
people out who work with us that's our
moral obligation and i also hope we can
diplomatically perhaps
help work for an outcome there that's
less bad than unfortunately the outcome
looks like it might be
but that's again where i think our
intervention both diplomatic
economic
as well as if need be occasionally
military is so important around the
world but just again the the notion that
you know austria i may have foolish uh
uh covet protocols now and people can
chortle about how that's like
totalitarianism but that's ludicrous
honestly and a discourse that can talk
about a u.s holocaust and about
authoritarian i'm not sure what term was
used so i don't want to characterize it
but talk about australia even in a
semi-joking way in the same way one
talks about genuine
genuine dictatorships that kill
dissidents and really oppress minorities
in horrible ways uh people who can talk
heavily about that
i don't know what to say
next question
i don't get to answer oh well jimmy what
yeah
on trivializing the holocaust
our government led by the
neoconservative hawks call every
opponent of the american government
hitler noriega's hitler david koresh is
hitler saddam hussein is hitler the
ayatollah khomeini and comedy or hitler
in fact just what six weeks ago h.r
mcmaster said that for trump to have
negotiated with the taliban that's just
like neville chamberlain negotiating
with hitler
well that to me sounds like it's
trivializing the holocaust either hitler
was a unique danger
or he wasn't
and i would say that he was and i would
say that when they bring up adolf hitler
the exception that proves the rule
in every single case where america has
to intervene oh oh muammar gaddafi the
guy from the naked gun 2 yeah no we got
to get him too he's hitler too
they're all hitler speaking of
trivializing the holocaust
uh comment bill
no
you want to pass you want to know you
want to pass
okay you want to pass uh question
historically it seems that empires don't
last question
yes so the question is
um
do you think world civilization has
changed that the united states would be
exempt
or do we end like end up like rome
england spain which one of them where do
you see us going
look historically republics don't last
either unfortunately and um so i don't
because they turn into empires
oh okay let him finish bill uh scott
yeah
so what is the implication of that that
i mean we need to keep a republic we
need to keep we don't have an empire we
have a
i call the benevolent hegemony to be
provocative but we have a liberal world
order which our power does undergird i'm
not willing i'm not backing away from
that i'm not you know
glossing over that
um are we overstretched were we
overstretched were we over ambitious and
what we tried to do in the middle east
perhaps i as i said earlier those are
tough calls but again the problem then i
think was a little bit too much ambition
in promoting liberty not that we should
not promote and defend liberty where it
is and there is a lot of there are a lot
of
i mean to look at this world and to say
that it's the you know a site of u.s
holocaust and i guess and of liberty
being crushed everywhere in the u.s
rampaging around again ask people who
like liberty whether they're in europe
or in asia or in latin america if they
just want the u.s to leave
or if they think that the u.s should
play a more active role in helping them
secure the freedoms which are universal
freedoms they are universal freedoms it
doesn't mean we can make them
make them universal and we need to
protect them here obviously so we can be
a republic but also i would say if you
want to use a provocative term we can be
at once a republican and a liberal
empire that's what the founders thought
honestly and i think we have done a
decent job of it for 250 years and i
think we can keep on doing it hopefully
for another children 50 years may i take
moderator's prerogative to uh to pick up
on bill's point made a few times uh to
throw it at you scott bill is basically
saying that that that a jury of people
who live in many of these countries they
support american presence and that so
that's his challenge to you what do you
say to the idea that people in east
timor and elsewhere want the u.s to be
involved what's your response
i've never heard of someone from east
timor wanting the u.s to be involved i'm
sure that i'm sure that when mr crystal
travels around to european capitals he
meets with people who like the american
presence there but the idea that that
means uh i mean i don't know somebody
showed me the opinion polls in
bangladesh and for that matter you know
in eastern europe that say that they
want the americans there and if let's
say
they hold another plebiscite this one
that american respects in ukraine uh and
99 of the people in ukraine want the
united states military there
but that increases the chance of a war
with russia
then who cares what they think this is
our country and you know what if i lived
in
probably any country in the old world
just the same as i live in this one i
would want to improve it but that's on
them and i do agree that liberty is a
universal principle of course it's a
universal principle but it must be
locally enforced because you see what
happens when the usa if you want to say
america is the best at it out of anybody
when the usa acts as the world
government they kill millions of people
in the name of doing good bill do you
want to respond to that point you want
to waive okay uh so let's see uh yeah we
have this side uh uh we i think this is
going to have to be our last question go
ahead i'm sorry sure this is for mr
crystal
um
so there have been um you claim there
have been successes and failures um of
the the post 1945 world order
how much worse would the failures have
to be or how meager the successes would
they have to be for you to say it wasn't
worth it we would have been better off
um keeping ourselves isolated
i mean it's a good question and
obviously when kent
we run we run history for 75 years
no i think you know nuclear weapons
being used several times europe's
descending back into war as it had twice
in the preceding half century in the
subsequent half century the cold war
ending with nuclear exchange or massive
uh conflicts of ground troops in europe
instead of the collapse of the soviet
union thanks to our partly partly thanks
to our pressure partly thanks to
gorbachev seeing that the soviet system
wasn't working and the power of example
mr horton cited also working but the
power of example doesn't go away because
we have troops in germany making sure
that the soviet union can't foolishly
decide one day to try to expand the
balance of the warsaw pact you know if
east europe hadn't become
central eastern europe hadn't become
free if we hadn't achieved the goal of
europe peaceful if we have taiwan and
south korea hadn't become democratic
nations i think all if japan weren't
still a democratic nation 75 years after
so i think if yeah if all those things
had gone south
or some of those things obviously the
balance would look very would look very
different the middle east is the
toughest place i will grant i think we i
don't think we made things worse there i
don't think we've made things as much
better as i would hope though i am still
hopeful the arab spring which
for various reasons didn't work so to
speak we didn't do as much to help as i
think we could have uh maybe we were
exhausted after iraq and and couldn't
have done much much more but it shows
that people there do
uh yearn for freedom and um
i do think there's much more we could do
diplomatically and in other ways civil
society to help to help even in the
middle east which is probably the
toughest part of the world for for my
case
uh coming from you scott on that
question yeah
well it's nato expansion in the
post-cold war era is the greatest threat
to peace in europe now
and we now share you know the nato
military empire hillary clinton said the
russians are doing exercises right on
nato's doorstep
she meant inside russia
because nato has moved their doorstep
all the way to the baltic states right
on their border and in the trump years
they actually had military exercises
within just a couple of hundred yards of
the russian border that's not keeping
the peace that's putting the entire
species at risk
thank you uh scott uh that closes the q
a uh and um
uh
bill crystal
uh
seven and a half minutes of summation
you want to take the podium again yeah
it's okay i can do it for you i think
okay i'm going to be brief partly
because i do have to actually catch a
plane as gene knows and i don't want it
therefore and i apologize if i seem to
rush out and not mix and mingle um since
there might be friends here from the
upper west side and elsewhere
i mean we have a fundamentally such a
fundamentally different view of the
world i'm not sure that we've been able
to convince each other i'm sure we've
not convinced each other anything and
i'm not sure we've convinced many of you
uh in this kind of debate i guess my one
i'll take this i'll just say this
you know what it's better to make one's
arguments assuming good faith on the
part of one's
the people with one whom differs once
opponents and assuming that maybe
they're wrong maybe i'm wrong i mean
that last question i think was a very
fair question and one could elaborate on
it in ways that i probably haven't
thought of and make more of a case that
we made more mistakes than i realize and
that things would be better if we hadn't
done if the u.s had been less ambitious
if we spent less on defense if we pull
back from the world um
or or not but the idea that you know
people
that
that what mr horton calls the
neo-conservatives or whatever don't want
the right kinds of outcomes is this
ridiculous as thinking libertarians or
whoever's for you know a republican not
an empire and for no american
intervention anywhere don't want decent
outcomes i think they're naive i think
they don't understand the way the world
would work and i think they don't learn
the lessons from history they might
otherwise learn but i understand that
most of those people don't go around
rooting for dictators to crush
dissidents or for countries to remain in
terrible poverty or for ethnic
minorities to be brutally slaughtered as
in xinjiang i don't accuse people who
favor a more dovish policies or china of
thinking that it's great that china has
concentration camps for muslims and in
the east but i i think making arguments
therefore on
the actual substance the actual
consequences of policies assuming that
the great majority of us on all sides
want the right thing is uh
is a better way to make arguments
[Applause]
we usually recommend the podium so uh
scott might as well check the podium you
have seven and a half minutes scott
are we still going to have a chance to
ask each other a question too uh no it's
over seven and a half minutes of summary
take it away scott all right
i'll email you bill
all right i
i think i've made myself pretty clear so
this thing is kind of busted um instead
of recapping if you'll allow i'd like to
just bring up a couple of things that i
had to cut for my opening statement for
time there
um is there any real benefit to the
american people
from our policy of global domination
including regime change perhaps access
to oil and minerals
certainly not
roger stern an economic geographer at
princeton university published a study
in 2010 which determined the u.s had
quote misallocated 8 trillion dollars
between 1976 and 2007 protecting the sea
lanes in and out of the persian gulf
when safe when oil safe transport was
never really under threat we spent a few
more trillion since then
this is far more than americans even
spend consuming middle eastern oil
even if somehow we could just scoop up
all the oil and walk away with it as
donald trump seems to believe it could
never be worth the cost in blood and
grief or the opportunities lost when
people turn away from america for acting
in such a ruthless manner they are
occupying and stealing syrian oil today
elon musk celebrated the coup against
the popularly elected government in
bolivia in 2018
crowing on twitter that it's great
because he needs their lithium for his
teslas
his company may have played zero role in
that coup for all i know but the us
government moved quickly to support it
and that still raises the important
question what is america's national
interest over the long term and is it
good for the rest of us when selfish
narrow special interests justify violent
intervention in other people's countries
for their own good in the short term
and let's just presume that the
financial gains far outweigh the costs
when companies like freeport mcmoran are
able to run off with all of west papua's
gold even accounting for the taxpayers
cost for u s government involved there
what shall it profit a nation if they
gain the whole world and lose their own
soul
you know by committing horrible deadly
sins against helpless people
part of the problem here is that the
neoconservatives and their neoliberal
counterparts never really understood
what liberty was about in the first
place
it's a great way to finance a pnac but
pentagon contracting is not the free
market it's corrupt crony capitalism
and due to the economic deformations of
america's permanent war system the most
wealthy counties in the country now are
not here in new york city
but in the suburbs of washington dc
where our supposed public servants live
and work
and the richest in this city as all
americans in the rest of the world know
are all market proof due to the
so-called greenspan put they get bailed
out by congress and the federal reserve
system every time they make a few
trillion dollars worth of bad bets
while regular people are forced to carry
their weight on our backs
their son our sons come home from war
unable to find good work
unlike in all the promises
and this is another major reason for the
current crisis of confidence by the
american people and our supposed bettors
who rule us
so no the nation as a whole doesn't
benefit financially or otherwise from
acts of violence and coercion by the
american government
read nsc 68
paul nitza did not understand economics
the whole imperial project is a fool's
errand and how much time do i have
three two okay uh and then i wanted to
mention somalia here because i had to
skip it for time in my opening statement
but it ain't fair that somalia always
gets skipped another six weeks or so
it'll be america's longest war
bush started supporting the warlords a
hunt down supposed al-qaeda terrorists
in somalia before the end of 2001
including the son of mohammed adid the
bad guy from the black hawk down
catastrophe of 1993.
those warlords made life miserable for
everyone until the people came together
to form a new government the islamic
courts union to force them out
bush then supported the ethiopian
invasion of 2006 which traded the
harmless islamic courts union for the
much more dangerous al-shabab insurgency
in 2008 secretary of state condoleezza
rice decided that icu chief sheikh ahmed
sharif could be the leader of the
country after all just within the form
of the new government the us had created
for them
never mind the last two years of killing
but al-shabab kept fighting and the u.s
drone war against them has continued
ever since
and as soon as us as the u.s ceases
support the government it has created in
mogadishu will surely fall just like
kabul
and kosovo in 1999
the war was in favor of secession which
is a regime change of sorts
this war put bin laden's friends in the
kosovo liberation in part in kosovo
liberation army in power including
hashem these the convicted organ thief
and gangster and guilty of prosecuting
and cleansing the serb minority there in
the inverse of the lies they told to
justify starting that war
bill clinton in the weekly standard
claimed that 100 000 civilians had been
killed
kosovar albanian civilians by the serbs
when the war was over the fbi found a
few thousand greys of fighting-aged
males and went home after two weeks when
the alleged mass graves containing the
hundred thousand killed were proven to
be non-existent
kosovo is now permanently dependent on
the united states where we still
maintain a massive military base there
to this day
so there have been no successes in the
war on terrorism unless you count
winning two iraq wars for the shiites
who despise us and continue to insist
that our troops leave their country
immediately
i don't
[Applause]
please open uh the voting for the final
vote but also uh uh
vote only now if your last name begins
with an a through m so just to segment
it pause the moment if you're not a
through m pause on the voting but a
through m please vote
uh and on the resolution uh yes no
or undecided a willingness to intervene
and to seek regime change is key to an
american foreign policy that benefits
america thanks to you both thanks to
scott thanks to bill crystal
for a spirited exchange
bill has
professional obligations in the morning
and has to take a plane
scott
isn't leaving until wednesday and so
he's going to be in the corner at the
entrance way and he's going to some
local watering hole that a local guy
will lead us to bill unfortunately i
know you'd probably love to come because
this is your own stamping ground but i
know you've got promises to keep and so
you're going to be taking off but
scott is going to be doing book signing
for his book enough already at that
place so if you want to congregate in
the corner there
at the entrance way then you can follow
scott wherever he leads you to where he
will be doing book signing and sales
so that's a through m has voted so now
uh n through the rest of the alphabet
can vote n through z
please vote on the resolution
and
we're going to be compiling a foreign
final tally
meanwhile i don't want to announce that
both of you were invited to our well
sorry
i don't know to our november 15th event
which will be downtown
actually legitimately in a seoul venue
uh you'll look it up uh that's going to
be a debate
on intellectual property
stephen kinsella versus richard epstein
stephen kinsella will defend the
resolution all
patent and copyright law should be
abolished that would be november 15th
downtown
december 8th we will have a debate on
vaccine mandates not held here
it will be a
the resolution defended will be ilia
someone versus angela mcardle ilya
silman will defend the resolution while
vaccine mandates are an infringement on
freedom some are justified due to their
big payoff in lives saved that will be
ilia simon someone george mason
uh
law prof versus angela mcardle taking
the negative uh we have another debate
now definitely scheduled in march
this will be garnet wagner versus
stephen conan
garnet wagner will defend the resolution
climate science compels us to make large
and rapid reductions in greenhouse gas
emissions
that's also scheduled for march you'll
find it uh in a couple of days on our
website so that's three debates that are
definite one that is up in the air
because dave rubin was going to debate
uh robbie suave dave rubin who's got an
enormous following he uh refused to come
on principled grounds because of the
requirements having to do with masks and
and vaccines and so we have to schedule
that elsewhere we're looking for a venue
for that that will be dave reuben versus
robert swaby it's definitely going to
happen one way the other
but probably not in new york city dave
rubin will defend the resolution
government must do something about big
tech censorship whether we like it or
not
that will be that resolution
and uh where do we stand on the voting
we still uh have a minute to go
okay we have the results okay
yeah
okay um
yeah um
all right the yes votes picked up
uh you didn't get but of course it with
the vote you get initially accounts
against you and so on expert voting you
know uh bill crystal had seven percent
of the vote and it climbed to nine point
four percent
congratulations there
but
now that's the number to beat but uh but
then the no votes went from 72 to 85
picking up 12 points so the tootsie roll
goes to scott horton but congratulations
to you both
[Applause]
[Music]
you